the Puritans have in many ways gotten a  bad rap  they weren't stodgy old people with  tired blood but instead they were  up-to-date highly educated and their  community in Massachusetts Bay was one  of the most highly educated the world  had seen before or since yes their ideas  were old they had a heritage so they  taught us to listen to our heritage they  listened to theirs theirs was drawn from  the greco-roman and judeo-christian  tradition and from those things they  learned and passed on to us the  importance of civic mindedness  the importance of the cardinal virtue of  justice they upheld the ideas of  education they were about the business  of founding Harvard right after getting  here and they passed the first public  school act ever in North America they  wanted to have a well-rounded educated  pious people who ordered their lives  according to transcendent moral truths  you